okay six one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty is the number our
caller from nine one seven is the next
caller 911 what's your name what's on
your mind today hi Henry
I was just wondering what your thoughts
are personally and also editorially in
terms of what you're going to cover when
it when a story regards personal emails
because I know for like the WikiLeaks
and the four wiki WikiLeaks packs of a
DNC emails people were finding those
personal emails but in terms of for like
the celebrity like nude pictures
personal leaks people refuse to read
those and for the Sony hack people had
issue with that also yeah there's a
standard right because on the one hand
you can say well listen what matters is
whether the people involved sending or
receiving the emails if they didn't
intend the emails to become public
then we should respect the privacy but
that applies both to elected officials
and to celebrities so in that sense it
seems that there would be a bit of a
double standard there's a subsequent
layer on which you could analyze it
which is well okay even if all of these
are emails that were supposed to be
private if you are an elected official
and you're supposed to be keeping
records in accordance with this that or
other law that is different than if
you're just a random celebrity who's
nude pics got stolen or whatever the
case may be that there's some difference
but I think you're you're right that
there is some degree of hypocrisy there
I mean I think bigger picture here's my
assessment of it right it's fine to say
let's talk about how we got this
information but let's also if the
information is newsworthy explore what
the implications are and that for me is
how you really drive a line between the
celebrity leaked emails or photos and
the political stuff which is yes both
the politicians and the celebrities
didn't want the stuff to be leaked and
it's okay to mention that there's no
newsworthy angle to the leaked celebrity
emails for example the implications to
the world of these leaked political
emails is significant and we can
still discuss that so I think that's
really the difference for me right but
do you think there's also a difference
when the others the other angle of the
government and the NSA reading personal
emails right and people say well
regardless of whether or not a personal
someone's personal email who the NSA is
looking into is relevant the principle
of looking into someone's personal
emails wrong oh sure that doesn't that
that's a bit of a different discussion
and that comes down to the legality and
effectiveness of surveillance and what
we want to accept as a society I mean I
think that it's perfectly fine to bring
that up but I think it's a bit of a
different question than the initial one
right okay all right thanks very much
appreciate the call uh yeah celebrity
emails I don't know that I've ever found
anything newsworthy Elite celebrity
emails not that I've spent that much
time looking at leaked celebrity emails
on yeah right